let's learn a little bit about the
gradient we'll use the same function
we've been using since we're pretty
familiar with its
with its
graph and its partial derivative so
let's say that f
of x
y
is equal to
x squared
plus
x times y or i can inverse certain xy
y squared now we're going to take the
gradient of this and then i'll give you
a little bit of intuition on what a
gradient is we're going to take the
gradient in
the in in two dimensional space and
you'll see what that means in a second
you can extend this to any dimension
so the gradient and we use this
vector differential operator
this upside down triangle the gradient
of f
is equal to
the partial of f
in the x direction
times
the unit vector i which is the unit
vector in the x direction so it gives
the magnitude of the slope in the x
direction and then it that's the
magnitude and then it points the vector
in that direction plus
the partial
with respect to y
in the j direction and obviously if
there was a function of more variables
you could keep going and you'd multiply
the magnitude of the derivative in each
of those dimensions direction
directions times the unit vector in that
dimension anyway what does this mean and
another way to view it you could have
also written this as
the gradient of f is equal to the
partial with respect to x
of
f of
x y
and then all of that in the i direction
this is just different notation plus the
partial with respect to y
times f of
x y not times operating on f and x y so
the partial of f of x y with respect to
y times
the j unit vector
and because of this notation a lot of
people view this delta operator and
actually is pretty consistent when we
learn about the divergence and the curl
a lot of people view this del operator
they actually define it they say that is
equal to the partial with respect to x
in the i direction
plus the partial with respect to y
in the j direction and then if you
wanted to do it into into three space
and i'll do that kind of in a that's not
going to apply to our problem because we
only care about two dimensions right now
and you'll see what i mean because even
though we're applying it to a three
dimensional surface but then you could
do the partial with respect to z
times the k vector and then you can
extend it to to n vectors but then it
becomes n dimensions but it comes very
hard to visualize actually it becomes
hard to visualize beyond what we're
doing right now
but so what does this mean
well it's
well before i go into what it means
let's actually calculate it for this and
then i will show you what it means so
what is
let's take the diet let's actually
calculate the diver sorry let's actually
calculate the gradient of f
so the gradient of our particular
function
it's the partial with respect to x
so we figure that out that's 2x plus y
and then that doesn't matter anymore so
it's 2 x
plus y that's the partial of this
function with respect to x
and we multiply that in the i direction
or the x direction
plus the partial with respect to y
and this is 2y plus x
2y
plus x and we calculated this in the two
videos on the on the partial derivatives
and we multiply that in the j direction
so what what does that look like what is
what are each of the components of this
vector
look like what is 2x plus y in the i
direction what does that vector look
like what does 2y plus x in the j
direction look like and this i have
graphed
so this is the same surface we've been
working with but now i've plotted these
points right here these are just points
that the software has picked to actually
display
these vectors and if you look at it this
this is the x axis and i can rotate this
i put it down a little bit and then i
can spin it around
i think that's pretty neat
but anyway
this parallel to this line is the vector
in the x-axis right so at this point
i've actually calculated the gradient
this vector says what is the magnitude
of this vector is the partial derivative
of the function or the partial
derivative of the surface or the partial
derivative of z with respect to
x
and its direction is just it just goes
in the x direction right because it's
that times the i unit vector so this
vector is the partial derivative of z
with respect to x
times the i unit vector at that point so
we just calculated the partial
derivative at that point it gave this
length
and then the direction is just the i
unit vector or in the direction of
increasing x
similarly this vector right here i hope
you can see it i can let me see if i can
actually zoom in a little bit that might
be
that might be useful
zoom in there you go
this vector and just so i wanted to see
the axes which you can't see now that
i've zoomed in but you took my word this
was the x direction now this is the y
direction or the same direction as the
j
unit vector right the j unit vector goes
in the same direction as y and the
magnitude is determined by the partial
derivative of z with respect to y
at that point and that's the magnitude
and we saw there was some symmetry so
the magnitude of this vector is the same
as the magnitude of this vector and then
when you add the two vectors together
you get this vector and notice that
neither of the
none of these vectors have any
dimensions in the z dimension they're
all kind of they're all kind of giving
you directions in the x y plane and why
is that interesting well the gradient
and this is the intuition the gradient
tells you the direction in the x y plane
you should travel
in order to get the maximum slope in the
z dimension or another way to view it
remember the partial derivative with
respect to x said what is the slope in
the x direction the partial derivative
with respect to y i said what is the
slope in the y direction but you could
take the partial derivative with respect
to any direction and the gradient gives
you the direction in which the slope is
the largest so let me zoom out a little
bit
is because i want you to see
i want you to see the
actual
axes
there's the axes
so all this says is if i in the in this
if i were to go in this direction i get
the maximum slope so if i go into this
direction my z goes up like that right
let me see if i can
rotate this a little bit
i don't want to scale it anymore let me
do the rotate it
let's see if i can show that to you so
if i go in that direction in the x y
plane
i get maximum z
so if i go in that direction i get a
maximum upward slope
that's what the gradient tells you
how do you get the maximum upward slope
and if you were to take any contour or i
guess you could say any closed line
where the z is constant
well actually i don't want to get into
that too much but you would
this gradient will actually be normal to
any or it'll be perpendicular to any
curve where z is constant
i don't want to get too involved with
that right now so let's go back here
so maybe it's more clear if we look from
below the graph
right so if you go to this point right
here this is the magnitude of this
vector
shows what is the slope in the x
direction the magnitude of this vector
is what is the slope in the y direction
and then when you add them two together
you get the gradient and the gradient
says well if i travel in this direction
in the x y plane
notice that none of these have any z's
right the the plane defined by all of
these vectors it's all flat in the z in
the z dimension
but if i were to travel this direction
in the x y plane
then i will get the maximum increase in
z per unit that i travel and let's let's
actually show you what it looks like in
the xy plane so if i just go head on
so i'm above the graph looking straight
down at the graph and then the colors
just show kind of you know where we are
but if we if we're down here if i if i
travel in this direction in the x y
plane i get my maximum increase in z if
i'm here
if i and notice here my
my the the x component of the gradient
is much larger than the y component so i
need to travel a little bit more in the
x direction and i'll get the maximum
change in z if i travel there another
way to think about it if i'm on if i'm
on a hill
the gradient
of that surface will tell you at any
point what direction you need to travel
in to get to to go
up the hill fastest or the direction
which the steepness of the he of the
hill is maximum this is more of a bowl
as opposed to a hill
but anyway
i'll just rotate it around hopefully
that makes some sense and i want you to
think about a little bit more and we'll
do a little we'll do a few more problems
where we just calculate gradients just
because i think it's useful to get the
mechanics but in my opinion at least the
intuition is a little bit harder to get
your head around than the actual
mechanics but once you get it it makes a
lot of sense i will see you in the next
video